she's someone I've been in love with
since I was 22 years old a public
declaration of love sealed with a kiss
after Drake missed accepting his own
moon man for best hip-hop video Drake is
stuck in traffic the rapper rushed to
the stage for a romantic recount of his
relationship with Rihanna that dates all
the way back to 2005 she was shooting a
music video at a restaurant called
avocado in Toronto
the song was pon de replay and the
director of the video was little eggs
flash forward to 2016 and director X
couldn't be prouder she's great she
deserves that award greatly she's one of
my best friends in the world all my
adult life I've looked up to her even
though she's younger than me
drinkin attacks Rihanna in a gown some
fans even thought he might pop the
question right then and there and
although there was no proposal he does
make it clear that love is on his brain
[Music]
but how does Rihanna feel about Drake's
live TV love fest now if you look close
during their kiss it seems like Rihanna
could be deacon out of the way and the
internet picked up on the moment making
scientists a trending hashtag on Twitter
but regardless of whether she curbed the
kiss or not it couldn't keep her away
after the show
here they are arm in arm backstage and
together again later in the back of a
car before making individual entrances
into the VMA after-party hours later
Drake shares his own side kiss shot on
Instagram from a night out in Toronto
back in early August captioning the
photo tonight we celebrate you Drake is
all about the romantic gestures a day
earlier you put up a billboard to
congratulate Rihanna on her big
achievement definitely not every day
something like that happens some people
cook some dinner
yum Xing never no billboards